changes février un château qui
appartient à la même famille depuis 1728
depuis trois ans avec son frère et sa
soeur laurence bizarre hamilton et
propriétaire du château
un défi de taille à relever pour la
fratrie première étape la grille
d'honneur du xviiie siècle
cette grille vous voyez l'ornementation
est en très mauvais état
beaucoup d éléments d d'état et des
armoires et la communion sont en train
soit de menaces est tombé soit de par
leur lisibilité les metal est devenu
très minces
donc on peut plus le décaper pour la
sauver la propriétaire a fait taper la
d'artagnan une plateforme de financement
participatif en faveur du patrimoine
le projet a reçu près de 40000 euros en
un peu plus d'un mois
un plébiscite qui permettra aussi de
payer une partie de la restauration des
murs des 12 on entame une démarche de
proximité avec les publics ont à vous
fait des réseaux sociaux que nous
n'avions pas et on sait qu'on a trouvé
que finalement partager la beauté des
lieux avec tout le monde c'est aussi
s'ouvrir sur les difficultés que l'on à
entretenir ce patrimoine donc c'était
naturel
à quelques kilomètres le château de gizo
utilise la même plateforme de dons ici
la chapelle fait face à un problème
d'infiltration d'eau ici vous voyez les
murs de la chapelle qui sont très
abîmées avec des trous avec énormément
de fissures les murs qui ont été peints
au 19e siècle est bien petit à petit le
plâtre peint ce d'école et tombe dix
mille euros ont déjà été récoltés sur
les 20000 demander un soutien des
internautes
vital j'ai eu c'est très grand c'est un
peu trop grand pour nos petites épaules
et donc de sentir qu'il ya des gens
derrière nous qui croient en nos projets
et qui nous aide vraiment concrètement
c'est c'est c'est super pour pourra
aller de l'avant et pour continuer nos
projets participer à la sauvegarde du
patrimoine
c'est donc possible dans la région la
plateforme a déjà permis de financer 38
autres projets
[Musique]